cuál es el costo de 14.6 litros de
gasolina si un litro cuesta 270 aunque
ya no tenemos los datos nos dicen que
son 14 puntos 6 litros de gasolina y
cada litro cuesta 2.7 que es lo mismo
que dos puntos 70 hagamos la operación
les recuerdo que cuando multiplicamos
decimales tratamos los números como lo
haríamos normalmente y al final nos
ocupamos de los decimales podemos
multiplicar esto como 146 por 27 y
después veremos lo de los decimales
hagamos la operación
vamos a centrar esto un poco mejor para
que podamos hacer las operaciones con
más amplitud
entonces comencemos tomamos este 7 y lo
multiplicamos por todo lo que está aquí
arriba 7 por 6 42
llevo 4
7 por 4 28 4 que llevo son 32 2 que
pongo aquí y 3 que llevo acá 7 por unas
7 más 3 10
ahora vamos a multiplicar este 2 y aquí
va a ir un 0 porque estamos hablando de
que vamos a multiplicar algo que está en
la posición de las decenas 20 por 6 ó 2
por 6 es 120 aquí ponemos el 2
aquí el 0 del 20 esto ya no lo hacemos
caso llevamos 12 por 48 más 1 que
llevamos son 9 y 2 por 1 esos muy bien
ahora hacemos la suma
y nos queda 2 2 más 2 es 49 2 más 1 33
mil 942 y lo que acabamos de calcular es
la multiplicación de 146 por 27 pero nos
están preguntando el resultado de 14.6
por 2.7 ahora es el momento de tomar en
cuenta estos decimales que ignoramos al
hacer esta operación contamos cuántos
números hay en total a la derecha del
punto decimal aquí hay un número aquí a
la derecha de este punto y aquí hay otro
número a la derecha de este punto
tenemos dos números estos son dos
números a la derecha del punto decimal
por lo que en el resultado vamos a tener
que este punto decimal de acá lo vamos a
recorrer dos veces hacia la izquierda 12
de manera que ahora el punto va a estar
acá 39 puntos 42 así que para los 14
puntos 6 litros de gasolina que cuestan
2 puntos 7 ó 2 puntos 70 cada uno será
de 39 punto 42